[Music]
name is David if today I am a researcher
in Microsoft Research AI in the adaptive
senses adaptive systems and interaction
group so today we are organizing co
organizing this session with on AI for
AI systems just a little bit of
background my background is actually in
either systems but it's actually machine
learning and robotics so this is a fun
anecdote I always like to say from my
robotics days at Carnegie Mellon we I
was once part of a team that was
building a big self-driving vehicle
awesomes not exactly a road vehicle but
an off-road vehicle and there was this
like you know large number of sub teams
and there was this one sub team which
was let's call them the rock detection
team and the rock detection team decided
that we are our aim is to build the
world's best rock detector so that
self-driving cars won't drive over them
and we can avoid them and do path
planning and everything pretty reliably
and robustly so they very quickly built
up the first nominal version and this
rock detector was was good it was like
you know on all our test datasets
proprietary test datasets they were like
70% accurate so to not hold up the rest
of all the modules that were being
developed by all the other teams they
decided that ok we will give we'll push
this out let the team work with that and
then we will come back and we will we
will try to improve it on the side while
the rest of the team's are using this in
the pipeline so six months later they
suddenly come back and they say hey we
now we have a 98% accuracy rock detector
and it works great and we have the same
function signatures and API interfaces
so just drag-and-drop this back into the
codebase pool do a pull request you are
good right and and so everybody was very
happy and they went and and they pulled
from upstream and then the system just
broke down and and this is a theme we
kept seeing over and over again that as
each individual module was improving
locally the entire system would degrade
and this is and when we realized that
like you know the systems that were
downstream from it are sometimes of an
upstream from it while learning to
compensate for different distribution of
outputs
and when I joined MSR there is an Eric's
group and Eric and me had always have a
dis long discussions about how we build
systems nominally and and the systems we
just like build them we try to do our
best to optimize them to make them as
fast as possible but our systems don't
reflect they don't adapt really and
through limited computation the concepts
of bounded rationality and and the fact
that we will always have partial
information and finite compute
especially on like you know edge
robotics the new classes of like you
know doing machine learning and
surveying or training as fast as
possible interactive systems so I felt
feel like you know this session is very
timely because justice systems has now
enabled a new revolution or the new boom
in in AI so as to speak and large big
data is now really big data and new
hardware new chips new systems are being
enabled there's also this like you know
question of like you know how do you use
AI to build better AI systems so it's
like kind of a nice self referential
loop and hopefully we will take off we
have an exciting lineup of speakers to
talk about all sorts of themes related
to this first of all we'll start with
Erik just just as a brief introduction
Erik is the director of MSR AI and he
also heads all of Microsoft Research and
we're very pleased to have him start off
and then he will be followed by Virginia
Smith who is just starting as faculty at
CMU talking talking to us about like you
know machine learning in the edge and
how to do federated learning better and
then we will have been asked from the
systems groups at Microsoft Research and
she will tell us about how the XI
learning is being used and what are the
problems in networking databases VMs in
the cloud and in really true big systems
how to do troubleshooting better but
without much further ado I'll hand over
the mic to Eric thanks I think I have a
mic that I'm actually wearing
so for many years since my dissertation
work I've been fascinated and intrigued
models of reflection in AI systems but I
mean broadly by that are representations
and inference strategies that actually
look look at existing uncontrolled or
unmoderated AI systems and that that
come to control them and optimize them
both for different kinds of
distributional settings shifts for
example in extremes of instances varying
amounts of time available for
computation to generalize the ability of
an agent to do well in open work in the
open world and so thinking more deeply
about potential architectures of
intelligence that might involve one or
more layers of reflection including
reasoning about reasoning or meta
reasoning and I thought I would just I
just mentioned for topic areas today
that I think that I'm that I think are
interesting directions in the realm of
reflection I'm learning to control
inferential processes given a base
process the idea of using portfolios of
components to to build rope more robust
systems meta-reasoning for ideal
allocation of resources for this idea of
being more flexible to distribution of
problem instances as well as to a
utility function for example over time
time criticality and then talking a
little bit about policies and
predictions for speculative execution
executing to with available resources
now about the future these are all
obviously interrelated topics so first
on this idea of leveraging learning to
control inferential processes so for me
the canonical problem in this realm was
some work we did that was published to
EU AI which was looking at a theorem
prover looking at np-hard problems to do
satisfiability constraint satisfaction
problems and
the related problems and we had access
to a theorem prover several theorem
provers actually and the basic idea was
we would be given hard problems and then
we'd run the systems and the community
noticed that a solution could be found
very quickly or take a very very long
time and I mean but like many many
varies in fact there's actually a
halting problem as well with some of
these problems with these with these
challenges and it was that was unclear
we actually knew how to discriminate
problems that would go fast versus slow
on top of that we had access to this
idea of randomization of a seed that
would start a new version of an of an
analysis of a problem and we can okay so
when you start a theorem proving problem
you can let the system run and run and
run and at some point in time you can
say you know what I'm gonna stop this
and restart it with a new random is a
randomized set eight set of settings and
try again
try to find a solution and it was notice
touristical e-bike are legumes actually
in Bart's Elmen that you could actually
by taking a whole bunch of a whole
workload of instances I'm running them
to a theorem prover and moving a restart
time for the distribution just like keep
on moving it and when you restart you
throw away all your your investment so
you're hoping to find a short run that
will solve your problem at the cost of
many runs and they were originally
setting these systems who say well I
wonder if we can do better than that so
the basic idea was we said what what
might we do from the point of view of a
machine learning problem to basically
look at this in a bayesian way and we
first said let's look at the instances
and try to characterize the actual
instance by feature izing it let's
actually the selfless feature eyes the
actual the environment where this the
generator that's generating the instance
is and then when you run the system
let's take a whole pattern of evidence
like actually we feature eyes the actual
search tree
what's happening in the in the in the
initial part of the run here and how
long has it been running became a
feature as well without finding an
answer so you can't meet that could be
part of your future space and magically
remember this actually actually was
running win mine on an airplane cut off
from the world in those days with this
big data set traveling across the
country and I did we discovered there
was actual rich signal in this in the
actual evidence being spewed from the
theorem prover you can read about all
the distinctions in the UAE paper to
build a model that would predict for any
run would this be a shorter long run in
advance of the run completing and we
actually this led to a body of
literature I mean of several papers
where we showed you can actually do use
machine learning to take a very hard in
a sort of an empty heart problem and cut
through the heart in this space with
Bayesian inference about when to restart
and randomized and showed how you could
extend the power of a very of it one of
the hardest AI problems we know they're
improving one example another example of
reflection I think we need to think more
about at the community is how do we take
portfolios of solutions and bring them
together in a coherent way to make more
robust reasoner's and the canonical
version of this for me is is a face
tracking problem that I worked on many
many years back but it's a very it
actually also resonates with today's
work and going on and even in this room
I say best something work in this space
as well to understand context based
performance an instance based
performance of of a machine learning
problem for example in this case was
looking at a face tracking here and the
idea is to take successes and failures
and build a model of confidence which is
so important in AI systems in the open
world
in this case we actually had this idea
of we we had an algorithm of a certain
type that would actually provide us we
were interested in the inferred state
where the face was there was the idea of
ground truth which influences that
and then we had this idea of of some
interesting variable here a very potent
one called inference reliability real
time reliability of inference and we
can't we couldn't see this directly in
our algorithms but we could actually
view what we called reliability
indicators and each algorithm we try it
had different reliability indicators and
a we called a different model for now it
turns out that we could use different
kinds of approaches in those days color
based model motion decay model he called
one it's like they have background
subtraction but the the fun thing was we
built a model for each we learned the
model for each of these things whoa were
together and boom we can that we had a
much more reliable face tracker but I
found most interesting in this approach
for the portfolio is there's a
independently developed algorithms of
course that you can find dependencies of
various kinds and how they work but I
was excited and you mean about this in
the paper in that we were now handling
unmodeled situations in the open world
so for example we never really trained
the system on this problem of facing
away from the camera or a jolted camera
or a peripheral distraction or the
person walking through the scene or
turning lights on and off but you see
for since these are very different
algorithms we and this it led to the
initial intuition as to how we built the
system to begin with this approach you
see in different settings one or more is
fuzzing out but the reliability
indicators are quite robust to capture
and wave and say I'm not doing well
right now wait things to that the
inferences from the other system and in
the end you ended up with a robust
output just a generic approach to
thinking through this the possibility
with you this with other algorithms in
the future especially independent cuts
on a problem that are each managed we
for and for each we have a reliability
signal no I'm never eating part deal
resource allocation it's a really a
powerful direction for systems were
building these days and I'll get into
that in a minute but I won't go back in
time for a bit to my own dissertation
work was very excited about this idea of
thinking through what I used to call
object level value
and then comprehensive value of any
inference in the world when you subtract
the cost of reasoning the cost of delay
so let's say we have an algorithm that's
producing and gives us some utility
function with computation time this
upper curve here in this case showing a
monotonic increasing with decreasing
marginal returns and the idea of some
notion of the cost of delay in this case
linear and if you just considered a very
simple model of we subtract the cost
from the value it's all in the same
scale you end up inside you have a net
value of action with time looking like
this this middle curve here and you see
there's an ideal stopping time and an
ideal amount of an optimal amount of
value you can squeeze out of this
algorithm in this current setting and if
you made the cost of time a little bit
more urgent he'll get more critical here
but costly in this linear sense it could
be any kind of function you end up
pulling back the amount of time you
should be dwelling and how the ideal
value you get out of the system now of
course for the distribution here this is
all uncertain and that's where it gets
interesting the expected value of
computation for example so one way to
exercise the system was to build
approximation algorithms for
probabilistic inference another np-hard
problem it turns out graphical models
and with time here one algorithm called
bounded conditioning with solve
decompose version of a Bayes net problem
with cycles and you can see over time
the upper and lower bounds are coming
are converging in this case it was
actually an urgent medical inference
where a patient is standing by with
gasping for breath and our systems
actually is predicting at any moment if
I invest this much more computation in
the system here's what I can expect the
balance to do per beam being converged
it turns out that you don't know where
the balance this our particular with
them you don't know where the bounds are
going to be you just know how tight
they're going to be so you're uncertain
and you can integrate over that and
compute the expected value of
computation for 10 more seconds or five
more seconds computation and therefore
have I have a stop
thing rule when the expected value
Titian goes to zero now this kind of
these methods turns out stimulate and
working in part there's if they cite the
old work in in the AI community in
psychology now and people are finding
these kinds of curves very similar
notions right now in humans and other
primates studies that are being done in
terms of responsiveness cost of the
urgency of a setting and how the ability
to do well with with incrementally with
more time but we talked about an
application now of this because of the
modern variants that the exciting me and
this is work led by day and and and
dambo and the idea is thinking through a
challenge we have an opportunity to
build what we call integrity of AI
systems that have many components in
particular these kinds of systems that
can do learning and imprints about a
social setting for example how many
people are in front of me what are they
talking to me was their attention what's
the next dialogue step what are people
saying the natural language processing
speech recognition acoustical analysis
of where the sounds are coming from in a
scene like the assistant by my door
which after how many years did we take
down seven years it ran straight helping
people mostly straight I would complain
when it was down like where's the
assistant and we got it back up again
but anyway here's an example of one of
these systems but you get a sense for
the kinds of things that you need to do
in these systems face tracking listening
this gives you a sense for the just in
this quiet video because if there's a
soundtrack here of how an agent what
might have to could what might work with
people the same thing with in this case
with physical and incarnations that are
physically embodied robotic settings a
lot goes on that requires multiple
components to work with one with with
with one another and so there's a it's a
platformer building and this it'll be a
workshop on this platform in a week or
so
okay week or so is good enough
approximation theater yeah from looking
at then leads the effort the sigh effort
which stands for platform for situated
intelligence but the idea is to build a
platform and programming model and
execute from runtime that can let let
you make it easier for developers to
build the system that could take in
multiple sources of input so it's
multimodal vision speech sound acoustics
and so on and then have many pipelines
that do a sense think act kind of loop
where timing is very important including
calling calling for cloud components
multimodal timing uncertainty and now
looking at meta reasoning and so quick
example here that they put together
leading this effort on the meta
reasoning challenge we have these
general graphs of components that call
each other and call upon one another for
example a system that might compute from
light our camera and radar steering
angle break force an accelerator in in
us in and out semi autonomous vehicle
might be some lost function function of
latency and accuracy and we might might
sort of figure out well how do we want
to prioritize and look at the trades
between how well each component is doing
how much precision we need versus its
Layton sees that might affect the whole
system and for the throughput of the the
system that's captured by a loss
function in the output here and one
example is what we're exploring is
likely have a face detector and and
landmark recognition component where an
image string comes in there are maybe
four different algorithms let's say and
we want to have some notion of of
computing latency and quality but right
now we're gonna saan latency and it's
refined this context dependent in terms
of in this case the number of faces in a
scene now we're looking at two different
settings here and what they did is work
and Dan worked very hard to characterize
how well how fast the system can respond
with a with a with a square a bounding
box around the face given different
algorithms and given numbers different
numbers of faces in a scene 0 to 4 in
this case
in terms of milliseconds if we actually
give this system come up with a utility
function here in this case around 450
milliseconds we basically design a
system that penalizes the the overall
function of the system based on time
after it hits after this this ideal
target point and then we want to sort of
reason about build the system I can
actually learn this automatically from
streams and so the approach right now
that's being explored is having a
meta-reasoning module that's actually
based on the theory around contextual
bandits that watches and observes and
tries to pick the right algorithm in
this case here's the really fun part
there's a resonate 50 model that's being
used looking at the raw video scene to
just give this contextual band that rich
context so it kind of some in some ways
sees how many faces by the high-level
feet by the by the features up to the N
minus 1 layer of the of the resin at 50
and then it also looks at the loss
function from the utility model as it as
it works and the contextual bandit runs
mostly inference but it also does an
exploit but also does exploration so
it's actually studying all the time so
as an example the video here the stream
coming into the face tracker and
algorithms 3 here you see the middle
curve here is the actual choice of
algorithm the top is the actual loss
function in the bottom curve is showing
the overall sits entire system latency
and going from a single face right now
to multiple faces and you see that these
little probes are actually the
exploration phase of the algorithm but
what happens is when it gets a bunch of
faces here the algorithm shifts to
optimize expected utility based on the
weight on the utility function here it
gets interesting because it's a pipeline
now suppose a mini pipeline but you can
imagine a future in future having a big
graph now given the bounding box going
to land market action five points
seven points eighty seven points more
precise landmarks on a face we need for
doing detailed tracking and
understanding of the face the same basic
setup now and what you see here now is a
analysis now of looking at two modules
and it's the unity we now go from to
twelve different algorithms because it's
a combination now but again going from
many faces to one face the system is in
real-time doing all this learning and
responding with the contextual band that
based on some theorems and and proofs
done about about what we expect from
contextual bandit models the the
long-term goal here is to take a big
graph someday built inside let's say the
preferred platform of choice for
integrative AI TM and automatically have
a system adjust how long each module
works with with sub algorithms being
selected to overall optimize the over
the the performance of a whole system
just briefly I'll end by saying that
I've been fascinated by this idea of a
computational ideal models of
computational anxiety what we what an
agent should be worrying about when it
has a little bit of idle time even when
it doesn't have idle time so the example
that I often give is a trauma care
surgeon is working on a patient and a
speaker lights up and there's a multi
multiple casualty case coming in
ambulances and a family coming in and
the the trauma care surgeon might stop
or slow down this case to just start
directing resources for that next case
coming in as the ambulance is on its way
in or multiple ambulances so you even
wanted reason about when you slow down
what you're doing now for the sake of of
your overall life history of your
responses to a stream for example in
this case so reasoning about probability
distribution of what's happening in the
future and speculating is important and
there's some nice theorems and and ideas
about this
actually would apply to speculation more
generally in the system's world which is
so important and systems often dunya
ristic ly taking algorithms from the AI
community and applying them in this way
if you could do what we call continual
computation using every single moment
ideally over time given a given your
current tasks and a probability
distribution over future tasks three
first of all that that's a real model of
intelligence because we're not here to
solve most of us one problem and then
die we're here to survive and have a
rich long history of successes and we
want to always be dreaming about the
future trading off the now for the
future and being ready for the
probability distribution of what's
coming next and this is nice give them
even some basic assumptions about
distributions and about our value of pre
computing them we can do quite a bit
with with optimizing our life histories
and so these ideas have been applied to
prefetching and webpages to pre
competing sets of questions that you
might ask in a in a like a medical
diagnostic system we it's really hard to
compute for example this value of
information applying this to navigating
through a geo database for example very
quickly where you get a sense by a
trajectory where someone is going and
you get a sense for a probability
distribution of needs and potential page
hits and misses or even a gaming engine
I'm in the cloud where you you know the
rules of the game you know the graphics
you know the needs and you can actually
start to use these principles to fetch
ahead one application that we're very
excited about I would from old research
to last week publication at PNAS you
just publish this work and this work
with his team came from some work that
from 1998 and Sikkim 2007 and triple AI
and now PNAS building on the same set of
ideas but the idea is very core I'll end
with this concept here very core notion
in systems how do we keep a
fresh think about this or in the same is
the same challenges how do we keep our
index of the web fresh how do we run a
web crawl so it's a very interesting
problem of an agent in the open world
multiple agents and the idea is you have
a say for look at the web problem many
pages with some knowledge about page
change rates based on their properties
in history potentially and you also have
knowledge about how popular pages what's
the utility function it's a function of
how all the pages of the cost and how
often it's being to be looked at turns
out that to solve that problem it's
generally a very hard optimization
problem Choa and Garcia molina showed
some up for small and how to optimize
that problem and as our here with with
with you've all myself the doctor
tahaafe with some interesting new
results have showed an N log n version
of this that's running at 99% optimal
it's a randomized probabilistic strategy
it's amazing you're taking this is for
synthetic data but we're now just say
Andre is trying this out with with real
data under under a couple of right now
working with us but this upper curve
here is opt and it's n log n methodology
as well showing how well we can do with
a probabilistic you seen your reputation
policy very exciting so there are rich
opportunities in applying AI for AI
systems and I was gonna say AI four
systems as well and getting down to the
bare metal which is refreshing a cash
thanks very much
I wish you didn't quit questions now
we're sure so this should have been in
that potpourri something for everybody
yeah
oh hi if if nobody asked I will ask you
and I have been in this business for a
long time so I was I mean you you ended
your talk on a very optimistic
futuristic fashion I am more concerned
about who knows how long I will be
around and so I'm more concerned about
next 10 years let's say and I'm a little
concerned that in in that respect we are
a little exuberant and over optimistic
because what you as a company customer
want is some kind of guarantees that
what you are going to give me were work
not 99% but then to minus 3% and I am a
little disturbed
especially coming from academia that we
sometimes oversell I am disturbed when I
hear that we can recognize with 85% when
I was young and we did simple pattern
recognition that was not considered a
result and you must remember that so I'm
a little concerned that we don't show
that under what conditions we can
guarantee that this will work and you
started your lecture with robustness
okay and then you kind of but I really
think that in order for us to get
credibility in the pub population at
large we really need to go back to the
guarantees and robustness I hope well we
should have a long discussion about this
but let me start by saying I only
abandon robustus because that was only
the first topic of for in 25 minutes
it's a very important topic for the
community and there's there's two
approaches to it several approaches I
should say let me point out the work by
Sameer and machine right now who just
gave a paper at H Kampf which is
building on a nice rich history of work
which is really really dissecting down
you know introducing new levels of
accountability to machine learning for
well calibrated and reliable error
signals based on context so it's a very
important area for us we just took it
hasn't been announced yet but we'll be
kicking off a significant effort with
MIT csail called trustworthy and robust
AI so it says we're not abandoning that
topic by any means of course it was the
first topic of my slides egg we're very
close with our Berkeley friends as well
and there's more discussion to be had
about that by the way but offline so and
and the other comment is if you have a
well calibrated error signal it probably
doesn't make a difference how poor your
inferences that just changes the
application and the design and the
appropriateness of using a technique the
hard problem is being aware and
sensitive and having subsystems and
super systems that understand how to
compute the reliability signal and where
this is a very powerful and important
area for our research here and we can
talk
that also offline thirdly I'll say and
we can go on again for a while now
Microsoft has been a leader externally
co-founding in the partnership on AI
where just today I tweeted if you want
to look for my tweet the working group
on safety and reliability published its
its first it's document it's charter to
publicly it's a it's a it's a that group
happens to be a multi-party stakeholder
group involving civil society as well as
technologists but this is a very
important topic I'll say that at
Microsoft we have was called the ether
committee AI ethics in effects in
engineering and research and safety and
reliable systems is one of seven working
groups very active co-chaired by Ajay
Kumar who's been working this base for a
while also so you're asking the right
people to be concerned I think it's
we're actually very it's a good concern
and we're with you on it so we'll talk
about Berkeley later offline students
when they present their results the
standard question I have don't show me
what you can do show me what your system
cannot do right and and as a warning to
the holy a community people that do
duplex demos or whatever demos you want
to do you can oh and the people who call
out the problems of AI it's easy with
probablistic systems to do a complete
video and expose of how terrible a
system is by picking some examples and
how wondrous it is if you just pick the
good examples and so we want to be
always be cautious about that and give
it give people a good representative
understanding of how well things do and
that's part of even coming for the
reliability score I think so I great
question and we can have a longer
discussion maybe later about that but I
I'm getting the sense that I'm giving
I'm actually giving Virginia even more
time than she needs usually for AV
problems so thank you very much Eric so
next we have Virginia Smith and
she is going to be faculty she already
actually started as faculty at Carnegie
Mellon University and she just finished
her thesis with Mike Jordan in Berkeley
and very excited to have her here and
thank you for flying out from Pittsburgh
I know it's hard because I used to go to
grad school there and thanks can
everyone hear me okay great yeah so I'm
excited to be here thanks for the
introduction today I'll be sharing some
of my work in developing system aware
optimization methods for the federated
setting so the motivation for this work
and for a lot of my work is thinking
about the machine learning workflow and
trying to make it more efficient and
more robust and more reliable so what do
I mean by the machine learning workflow
this is a very coarse description of the
workflow you start with your data set
and the problem that you'd like to solve
let's pretend it's something with cat
pictures that tends to happen a lot
under the hood then you select your
machine learning model and then to
actually fit that model to your data you
often have to select an optimization
algorithm it's actually trained that
model okay but often this workflow is
not happening in isolation it's
happening together with some sort of
system and this system and the
parameters of this system have a very
large impact on the optimization
algorithm that you select to fit your
model to your data so one area that
system aware optimization has a great
potential to to really improve things is
the federated setting so in federated
learning this is of just a term that's
been coined to describe the problem of
training machine learning models at the
edge so as opposed to a traditional
cloud-based training where you might be
storing a model on the cloud and
training on the cloud when it comes time
for prediction you send raw data from
the devices and then you get the
predictions from the cloud here we're
trying to push some of the computation
and offload it onto the devices
themselves so you can store the the
models on the devices and you can also
perform training at the edge so what
that looks like is instead of actually
shipping the raw data you can send
down stream model updates and aggregate
them via the cloud and then come to
consensus on some sort of global model
that you ship back to the devices so
this is becoming more and more feasible
as devices grow in terms of their
computational capabilities it's a nice
thing to do because it allows you to
quickly incorporate new data that you're
seeing on the devices it also helps to
reduce the strain on the network because
they're not having to ship this raw data
and it helps to increase the privacy
guarantees that you can provide again
because you're not shipping the raw data
you're shipping these downstream model
updates so what are some examples of
applications that fit into this sort of
setting you can imagine things like
language modeling for speech recognition
on on mobile phones adapting to
pedestrian behavior in a fleet of
autonomous vehicles or predicting health
events like low blood sugar from
wearable devices so not all applications
from you know the IOT setting fit into
this setting but many do and the key
sort of assumptions are that the local
data that's being generated on each
device is important potentially more so
than some proxy data that you could use
if you were training this model just in
the cloud for the problems that we're
looking at we're looking at supervised
problems where we're labels need to be
available and then another another
reason why these types of problems are
becoming more and more interesting is
that privacy is often a very important
concern and so not having to ship that
raw data for applications like this
helps to enable privacy guarantees okay
so what makes this problem difficult why
is it difficult to solve optimization
problems in the federated setting in
particular why is it that we can't use
traditional distributed optimization
methods that have been developed over
the past decade and more that have been
developed for the data center setting
the issue is that traditional data
center distribute optimization methods
face suite of new challenges when
looking at the the Federated setting
so in particular in the federal setting
communication can be more expensive than
in the data center setting so you might
have rather than hundreds to thousands
of machines you might have thousands to
millions of devices in the network and
the network itself can be slower than a
traditional data center so you can
imagine a mobile phone network network
where some of the phones have very poor
network connection additionally there's
a huge amount of variability in the
network itself so you might have as
compose as compared to a data center
setting where you might assume that most
of the machines have similar
computational power here you could have
some devices that have very different
computational abilities and others you
might have certain devices that are very
old versus very new devices some that
have very low battery power or poor
network connection and these things can
really affect stragglers in the system
and it can also affect issues like fault
tolerance so at any given round in a
network with a million devices you could
imagine that many of them if you're
trying to do some sort of computation
are offline or trying to do some some
other sort of computation so you can't
count on them for computation at every
round so fault tolerance is a big issue
in this setting and I'll note that this
heterogeneity this this variability
comes not only from the system's
perspective but also from the
statistical point of view the issue here
is that we're generating data on these
devices and we're also trying to store
and process that data and so some
devices might generate much more data
than the others and this can lead to
very unbalanced data across the network
so the statistical unbalanced presents
issues in terms of how we actually solve
this optimization problem but it also
presents issues in terms of how we model
the problem so in particular
personalization is really key in this
setting the data that's being generated
on each of these devices can be
generated in a very non identically
distributed manner so you might have
certain devices that generate data
that's very different from the others
for example if we're thinking about
trying to develop voice recognition
models my voice recognition model might
be very different than someone else's
because we're generating different sorts
of data so in the talk today I'm going
to talk about two methods that that
we've developed recently to try to
handle some of the
challenges one is fed cocoa which is a
method for handling some of the system's
challenges in the federated setting and
the other is mocha which is something
that builds on on these ideas to also
allow for personalization so first in
terms of developing a distributed
optimization method for the federated
setting again what is the issue with
with using something like a traditional
data center distributed optimization
method well this is a question that I
asked myself because this is what I
spend a lot of my thesis working on so
for example if you look at some results
from the data center setting with with
state of the art methods you'll see
results like this so on the x-axis here
I'll be showing the time in seconds and
on the y-axis the distance to the
optimal so the goal is to get down to
the to the bottom of this plot as
quickly as possible what you see in the
data center is that if you compare two
methods that have been developed and
tuned for this data center settings such
as cocoa which was the focus of my
thesis work you can get these massive
improvements over other traditional
methods like mini-batch stochastic
gradient descent or mini-batch
coordinate descent okay so for example
for this this problem and this cluster
this was a 40 X feet up it meant that
the training time went from two hours
down to just roughly three minutes so
this makes a big impact in terms of your
overall training expense so these
methods work well in the data center
setting let's see what happens though
when we when we apply cocoa to the
federated setting so what you see is
that in terms of the time and seconds
here to get to the optimal cocoa is not
really doing that well and in particular
it's not doing much better than these
other baseline methods and the reason
for this is that there are these
additional constraints and challenges of
the federated setting that have not been
well modeled by this this optimization
method so what we'll show you today is
basically how to improve upon this with
this method that we're calling Fred
cocoa to get these very large
performance improvements
okay so I'm going to backtrack a little
bit now and talk about how KOCO works to
show you where it's falling short which
allows us to develop this more tailored
method for the federated setting okay so
the motivation for cocoa comes from the
fact that there are two sort of extremes
currently and thinking about how to
perform optimization in the distributed
setting so the goal again is that you
have a bunch of data that's distributed
on on different machines or devices so
imagine each of these dark grey
rectangles is a data point and each of
these light gray squares is either a
device or a machine the goal is to
process all of this data and to try to
find the optimal machine learning model
knowing that you have to communicate
back and forth with each of these
devices at each round so how can we
perform this communication on one
extreme you could take something
basically that works well on a single
machine and try to sort of naively
parallelize it into the distributed
setting this would be something like a
traditional mini batch method mini batch
stochastic gradient descent for example
this method works by at each round
selecting a data point or a subset of
data points at random and computing
something like a gradient from those
data points sending those updates back
to the master applying them to the model
and iterating doing this over and over
again until convergence is reached so
these methods are very popular and
they're nice because we have nice
convergence guarantees about these
methods but in general they can be very
slow in the distributed setting because
you'll be communicating very frequently
between the machines and the master so
what else is there on the other extreme
there are methods known as one-shot
communication schemes where instead of
processing one data point or a few you
process all of the data points
completely you completely solve separate
models on each of the machines and then
you do something like average them at
the end so this is the other extreme it
says never communicate or only
communicate once at the end it's it's
great because it's really fast but in
general convergence is not guaranteed so
you don't have the same sort of nice
theoretical properties that you do from
the mini batch methods so
and putting this together the nice thing
about Coco the reason that it is a great
method to use in the data center setting
is that it helps you to go between these
two extremes
so in particular coco takes this one
system parameter of how much do you do
local computation versus communication
and it exposes it to make it as flexible
as possible so you can tune this amount
of local computation versus
communication how is Coco actually doing
this so the method is actually very
simple basically what it does is that
the goal is again to find some model
across all of the data how can we do
this we can take this global problem and
split it into subproblems one for each
machine so each machine is trying to
find some solution to its own local
subproblem it tries to find some updates
to that subproblem sends those updates
back to the master applies that to the
to the model and then iterates doing
this over and over again but the thing
that makes Coco really flexible is that
in performing these these updates to the
local subproblems
it makes the following assumption it
assumes that each of these subproblems
is solved to accuracy theta so this
theta parameter is really flexible
because theta is just a number that can
go between 0 & 1 where when theta is
equal to 0 it means that all of these
problems have been exactly solved on
each device whereas if theta is closer
to 1 it means that you are in exactly
solving the solution perhaps you're just
doing one or two updates locally so by
tuning this parameter you can tune
roughly the amount of local computation
versus communication so this seems like
a great set up to use in the federated
setting where you have this issue of
expensive communication however there's
one issue with this data parameter which
is that theta is not truly that flexible
and that you have to set it once for the
entire method so the state of parameter
is consistent across devices and across
iterations the reason that this is such
an issue again is because we have issues
in the Federated setting with
statistical heterogeneity some of the
subproblems might be harder to solve
than others which would affect this
theta parameter you might also have
issues with systems
heterogeneity so some of the devices
might not be able to compute good
solutions to their sub problems because
you know they're not connected to the
network they have low power low battery
level or just their hardware is worse
than the other devices in the network
okay and finally you can also have
issues with devices actually just
dropping off and going offline
and that's not accounted for in the
original Koko method because in Koko we
don't allow this parameter to exactly
equal one meaning that you have to send
some update okay so what do we do in
federated Koko to handle this basically
we make this this simple change so we
change data to be something that you can
vary both by iteration and by device and
this looks deceptively simple but what
becomes difficult is actually showing
that the method can still converge given
that you've done this and what we're
able to show is that using this much
more flexible accuracy parameter with
the simple assumption that the same
device doesn't not send information
every single round so you have to
eventually get an update from one of the
devices otherwise you won't be able to
to reach the optimal we can show to
convergence guarantees one for L
Lipschitz losses this is something like
the support vector machine model you get
a 1 over epsilon rate of convergence and
you can get a slightly faster rate of
convergence for smooth losses things
like logistic regression or linear
regression okay so this is nice because
now we have this set up that is much
more flexible and more tailored to the
Federated setting and we have nice
theoretical convergence guarantees about
it but how does it perform in practice
so what we've done is we've gathered
some real federated data sets from
things like a sensor network Google
glass data
human activity recognition on mobile
phones and you can see what's
interesting is that these real federated
data sets really are quite heterogeneous
so you can see that the the minimum and
maximum number of data points per device
really does change significantly for
these data sets I'll just show one
example of the results you can see that
federated cocoa in terms of the time in
seconds is able to converge much faster
than
traditional coco and these sort of very
popular mini-batch style methods which
are used frequently in the distributed
setting so in particular for this
problem that we were looking at we're
able to converge to the same epsilon
accurate solution two orders of
magnitude more quickly and what was
interesting is that we also got to look
at what would happen if we just dropped
devices out of the network how would
that change the performance of the
method and what you can see is that as
long as we don't drop out one device
every single round which is what is
shown in this green dotted line the
performance of federated Cocoa's is
fairly robust to this issue of devices
dropping out okay so I wanted to talk
briefly as well about what we've done to
handle personalization so going back to
this this workflow one thing about the
Federated setting is that it's really
impacting not only how we solve this
optimization problem but also how we
model the data itself okay and so
thinking about how to model federated
data two extremes are you could imagine
just selecting a separate model for each
of the devices in the network this is
this is nice because it allows you to
personalize to the local data that
you've collected but it's not great and
that you can't really learn from the
other devices in the network if you're
learning a separate model for each of
the devices then you're not able to
aggregate the information and learn
across the devices on the other extreme
if you learn just a single model for all
of the devices you're you're helping to
learn from the the peers in the network
but you're not really personalizing the
information that you have so what we
want is something in between we want to
be able to personalize our models but
also learn from the aggregate
information and boost the effective
sample size of each of the devices so
how are we doing this one one nice way
to set this problem up is through
something called multitask learning so
in multitask learning you have you do
you do exactly this basically you're
trying to find some local model for each
of the local data sets these local
models these local models are all and
captured in this aggregate matrix w and
then what the objective is doing is
basically enforcing that these models
follow some structure where structure is
enforced through this task relationship
matrix Omega so the reason that this is
really nice is that you're trading off
between trying to find the optimal
models for each of the devices as well
as enforcing some structure across those
models so this allows you to have
personalised models that also share and
learn the structure across them so this
set up for example can capture things
like all of the tasks being related
most of them being related but there
being some outliers clusters or groups
or things like asymmetric relationships
for example you might have a power user
in the system that is performing most of
the the interesting information so you
can capture relationships like that as
well okay and we looked at at using a
multi task set up with the real
federated data sets that we collected
and what we saw is that the multi task
set up compared to the completely global
or completely local models consistently
got better prediction error in terms of
the problems that we were looking at so
you can see this this right-hand column
each of these prediction error numbers
are significantly lower than the other
two models and this makes sense because
the multi task setup is really able to
go between these two extremes of a
completely global or a completely local
model so with this in mind the key
question then was how can we take this
nice multi task learning framework and
apply it to some of the federated cocoa
work that we had that is looking at
trying to actually solve this problem in
the federated setting so in particular
we want to be able to solve this new
broader objective in the federated
setting if we're looking at this
objective one thing that's nice is that
if you solve for these two terms
competing terms W and Omega in the
alternating fashion Omega is in fact
quite easy to solve you can solve that
just with the models W but without
access to any of the Federated data but
W is what needs to be solved in the
federated setting so the key question
was how
extend this update to W to work with the
federated cocoa method that we had
described from before okay and I miss
kind of the the key idea of of how we
actually form these subproblems when I
was describing them earlier and this is
really important if you want to think
about extending it to another type of
objective and so recall that the way
that federated cocoa and cocoa work is
that basically you're you have some
global problem of interest the way that
you actually saw this global problem is
by splitting it into subproblems one for
each device and so the way that this
division is happening is actually very
closely tied to the mathematical
formulation of the objective function so
in particular what we do in cocoa which
is nice is that the the primal problem
here is a bit difficult to solve it's a
bit difficult to distribute this in two
separate subproblems because you have
data points that are touching each of
the bottles of interest W and so what
you can do is instead of looking at this
primal formulation you can instead
consider the dual so this is a very
common trick that's often used in
optimization because this problem is
convex the dual will still arrive at the
same solution as as the primal but this
dual is actually much easier to separate
because you have one dual variable per
data point and so this separates much
more nicely across the machines okay so
and what I'm saying is mostly true
except for this this regularization term
here and the way that we handle that in
cocoa is by doing a quadratic
approximation to this term so
essentially what's happening is that at
each iteration we're computing a
quadratic approximation to the true
objective in the dual okay
so that was that's kind of the the
secret sauce in the back of how we're
actually taking this problem and
distributing it across the devices but
it's important to consider this because
then the key challenge is how can we
take the same idea of using the primal
and the dual and apply that to this this
multitask learning objective okay and
I'll just summarize this quickly by
saying basically we can we can do
something very similar where the dual
love interest looks like this and we can
find a subproblem very similar to what
we had done in cocoa and federated cocoa
where basically where we're looking at
this jewel and forming a quadratic
approximation around it okay so putting
these all together just to kind of recap
this was nice because we address some of
these key challenges in the federated
setting that really differ from the data
center setting in federated cocoa we
handle things like expensive
communication by taking the problem and
putting it into these subproblems that
are solved to approximate accuracies and
we allowed these approximate accuracies
to be highly variable which helps to
deal with systems heterogeneity then
with mocha we also looked at the the
statistical issue of personalization and
we show that we can take that model and
also apply this similar ideas as in
federated cocoa so end with two quick
slides in terms of where this is going
next so I'll note that there are a lot
of other exciting areas and open
research opportunities in federated
learning so one is that the problems I
talked about today are were all convex
deep learning is also of course very
popular and is non convex so there are
interesting opportunities in thinking
about how to extend this the non convex
setting there are a lot of interesting
open problems to deal with privacy and
security around a solution like this
so certainly federated learning improves
upon sending just the raw data but those
model updates you also make sure that
those are secure we talked about
personalization through multi task
learning there are other ways to provide
this like transfer learning our model
fine tuning we reduce communication by
making this accuracy parameter very
flexible there are other ways to reduce
this even further things like
compression or lazy aggregation and
finally in terms of the machine learning
pipeline I've been focusing on the
training portion there of course other
ways you could think about addressing
the machine learning pipeline in this
edge scenario things like doing on
device feature extraction or on device
inference so this is there's a lot of
open and exciting research directions
within this area
in terms of my own research I'll note
that one thing I'm excited about is you
may have noticed some of the federated
datasets that we were looking at we're
very small and so we've been working
with some collaborators to develop
something called leaf which is a
benchmark for federated data it will
contain a suite of open-source datasets
and evaluation framework to help frame
some of the statistical and systems
metrics and questions and it will be
online very soon so please check back on
my website because it'll be releasing it
in the next few months and sorry last
thing so there's been a lot of exciting
work around systems and machine learning
obviously at the summit today and within
this session and I myself and serving as
program chair for a new conference on
systems and machine learning called
sysml so sysml the goal of the
conference is to elicit new connections
between the two fields and to make sure
that these discussions are happening not
siloed within their own research
communities but in a collaborative way
so this last year we held a one-day
conference with over 300 attendees and
200 submissions this next year 2019 will
be a full conference three days with
published proceedings so if you're
interested in that please take a look
the submissions are due at the end of
September and the conference itself will
be in Stanford and the end of march
through April of 2019
so thanks that was all I had and I'd be
happy you're happy to answer questions
[Applause]
so I got a question about the privacy
aspect of a other federated approach of
I mean it seems to me that if I'm
worried about the privacy of my data
then it should only be used locally
right and especially if it's gonna be
for our personalized model right and not
be sure at all with the cloud but
sending model updates it seems to kind
of like open a whole kind of warms we
like model inference attacks and things
like this what it's not really clear
you're not gonna be leaking basically
yeah that's a great point I think
there's a trade-off there if privacy is
the most important thing to you more
important perhaps than the accuracy that
you're getting then certainly it makes
sense to keep that data completely local
the main thing that the Federated set up
is is positing is basically that sending
model updates is a better alternative
than sending the raw data which is
what's you know frequently done in a
cloud-based situation where you have the
model on the cloud you're sending the
raw data up to get predictions so I
agree with you that the model updates
themselves could also be an issue and so
there's some weeks there's some
interesting work looking at combining
that with differential privacy to ensure
that the model updates that you send are
in fact private but I think that there
is a trade-off because if you keep all
of the data completely local then you're
losing some of the interesting
information and data that you could get
from devices like yours so yeah I'm the
question about the personalization so
I'm not a machine learning person but
can you give some examples so I'm kind
of trying to understand what the
limitations of it is in terms of you
know is this about different phones
having different types of sensors or
people having different preferences so
yes I think the example I gave before
was that for example if you have if
you're trying to train a model for voice
recognition on your
if you train a single model for voice
recognition across all voices it could
be that that doesn't perform as well as
one that's personalized to the specific
voice of a specific person and so
certainly there are some aspects of
speech that are going to be the same
across all people but you could also
imagine that certain aspects of the way
that a person speaks or their accent
also influence speech recognition and so
that's the trade-off where you want to
do some global modeling but also have
some amount of it that is local or
personal to the data thank you very much
and then you're going to have our next
speaker very excited to introduce Ben as
our Johnny and she's from MSR as well
and she's going to tell us about self
emerging networks and hopefully will not
have any networking problems ever again
except we have except we have AV
problems
I have one in my back I can use mine
okay sorry everyone so today I'm gonna
be talking about this is more of a
networking talk I'm not really a machine
learning person but what I want to talk
about is how we move towards network
think and manage themselves and what I
want to do is sort of talk about what
I've learned through my research about
where machine learning can actually help
in networking so the picture I have here
is of Albert Greenberg and he's the head
of Azure networking and he has a
thousand 29 reports and if you look at
what these people do on a day to day
basis
a lot of their time is spent on managing
and configuring networks and if you
think about when networking as a field
started the first paper on networking
was in 1973 sitcom started in 1969 sig
metrics has been around since 1971 and
then NS yeah I started in 2004 and yet
we still need people to actually
actively configure and manage our
networks so what I wanted to do is to
try to understand why do we still need
this like why are people spending so
many hours and so much money just on
configuration and management and so what
I'll do is I'll talk about what my
research in collaboration with Azure
over the last few years and what I'll
describe is what I've learned to be the
cause of this problem and where machine
learning can come into play to help
solve it and this has a couple of
different aspects that one aspect is
diagnosis the other aspect is security
and then I'll talk about what were the
common themes and how can actually I
help with it so I borrowed this slide
from I'm in Baghdad whose basic
the counterpart of Albert Google and
according to have availability is the
main foundation on which our data
centers are built so we want them to be
manageable we want them to be performant
but if they're not available we did get
none of that benefit anyway and so the
first thing that can disrupt that is
going to be failures right so failures
are going to hurt our availability and
to give an example why it is a diagnosis
is hard is think of the scenario you
you're a researcher you want to use a
cloud you bill boot up a cloud VM you go
over the cloud network and then you
connect to some service and so when
something goes down if you imagine that
the network is mine is managed by a
juror and then the store the service
could be managed by some other company
the problem that this causes is when you
have a failure you can have one of two
situations either someone accepts
responsibility for the failure
so either the network operator looks at
their networks and figures out oh I know
what you this happens or on the other
hand the service operator looks at their
system and finds a cause of the problem
in that situation you can eventually
figure out what was the root cause and
solve it but often you run into this
particular situation where the network
starts blaming the service the service
Flav's the network and nobody really
wants to take responsibility for this
and we had a real example of this
happening in agile networking where we
had VMs that had that were connecting to
virtual storage panic and reboot because
their connections to storage were
failing and in these situations we had
tickets created that were basically
showing customers are being impacted but
nobody was willing to take
responsibility for it so storage was
blaming network network but was blaming
stories but and the problem was not
getting resolved well the question was
how can we actually attribute blame to
the right team so we created a system
that was published in sitcom 2016 we
call it net poro
and the main requirement for it was that
it didn't require anything to be
installed in the network or storage
because neither one of them wanted to
have that overhead but would still be
able to say who is responsible for the
failure when
when the failure happened and what we
decided to do is take advantage of an
hour protocol to call TCP now TCP is
designed to be able to detect Network
failures it's designed to be able to
give you reliability when you're going
over a best-effort distributed system
that is not guaranteed to deliver all of
your packets but then our theory was if
it's designed to detect failures in the
network can it distinguish between
failures in the network and failures on
the server side and so we took a bet and
what we did was we did it with design
this is some over that looked at TCP
statistics we gathered from the hosts so
it doesn't gather any data from the
network or the service and try to
identify if we have a client-side
failure or a server-side carry network
failure so the way the system worked is
we had a monitoring agent that was
deployed on all hosts across Asia
eliezer data centers and we injected
failures onto a subset of these machines
to look at what failures look like in
terms of TCP statistics and then we
trained a simple random forest model
using this data to see if we could
actually distinguish what was causing
the problem and then this model was
running on each of the hosts to figure
out why the VM is rebooting and it
turned out with that to work really
really well so we solve that problem we
still had one more which was ok now I
know that that I have failures in my
network and it turned out actually 20%
of the time those failures were in the
network then we ran into in separate
situation where you could have multiple
links in your network having failed or
be dropping packets at any given point
in time and you can actually have a link
with a high drop rate and a link with a
slightly lower drop rate but you care
about one of them more because while the
liquid hydroplate is dropping a lot of
packets is not impacting any customers
where the customer is not noticing that
packet drop rate versus there's other
lower draw a packet is impacting
customer whose application is very
racist sensitive to this type of failure
so what we wanted to be able to do is
associate failed links with the problems
that they're causing so essentially we
wanted to say this customer is impacted
by that link failure this customer
impacted by this sling failure now here
we actually didn't use machine learning
but I'll talk about how we actually
solve the problem but before I do that
I'll talk about why it's actually hard
so in an ideal situation what you want
to do is say this is the connections
that this guy has these are the
connections that this guy has if I know
where my failures are I can basically
map the failure to the connection and
then solve the problem but the problem
is operators don't always know where the
fail links are either right and if you
think about the scale and which data
centers operate this becomes an
extremely hard problem is basically like
finding a needle in a haystack
and the thing is we also have packet
drop rates that are bad because of the
normal day-to-day operations of the
network so tail drop late race happen
and you detecting them doesn't really
give you anything you can't take any
action on those prototypes of problems
so one of transient drops do occur on
many links and they add noise to the
diagnosis problem and so the
requirements that we were asked when we
were solving this problem was to be able
to detect short-lived failures to be
able to detect concurrent failures and
we wanted the approach to be concurrent
robust to noise but again like the
previous approach we again had this
mandate from the network operators where
we were not allowed to deploy anything
on the servers or anything on the
network so we had to again use an
approach that was only on the client
side so the strawman solution to this
would have been something that is
traditionally networking known as
tomography the way it works in this
example is a following if you have a
simple topology where the link between
four and two is bad and you have three
connections you can basically assign a
variable let's assume you know the path
of each of these individual connections
for now right you can assign a variable
to each of the links and you can form a
system of equations that equate zero if
there is no failed link along the path
any quick one if you have a failed link
along your path and by solving this
system of equations you can basically
figure out which link is in your network
and fail so the easiest reason why this
fails is that you don't always have
enough flows to be able to have a full
solvable set of equations there are more
problems beyond this one hour things to
a point in the sense that it's really
hard to have the path of every single
flow in your network and a lot of other
things and I won't go into the detail of
that to bore you but we had a system we
call double-oh-seven that was published
in an STI 2018 that basically tries to
solve this problem and I'll just give
you a teaser of how it works and the way
it works is we have again an agent
that's only on all hosts in Azure so
it's on the client side and it monitors
TCP connection is running on these hosts
every time there's a packet drop this
Aiden gets notified that a packet drop
happened and the hosts then vote on the
status of the links so the way the
voting works is in this case this
connection didn't experience any
failures all links get a vote of 0 1 & 2
and we actually have a theoretical
guarantee that this this is supposed to
work that is resilient to noise all of
the stuff that operators care about now
in the context of security I've also
been looking now at a problem again in
collaboration without your networking
and here this is a completely different
flavor than what I was talking about
earlier what we want to be able to do is
to detect compromised the ends it's a
very simple problem and if I have
anti-malware on my all of my VMs in an
ideal situation I really don't have a
problem anytime IBM gets compromised the
anti-malware should be able to find it
and I'm good the problem is that in
reality this is what the system looks
like a lot of customers don't want to
have a microsoft owned anti-malware
software on their machines so a lot of
these VMs are not protected so then the
question is how do I protect those VMs
because these VMs can now cause damage
to other VMs that are running in the
same data center and the way we ended up
decided to do this was based on a theory
we thought that if compromised VM live a
network print then maybe the connection
graph changes significantly enough when
a VM is compromised from his past
behavior for us to be able to detect it
so this is ongoing work but right now
the results seem rather promising so we
don't know if it's work it will work or
not but
what I want to do want some now that
I've talked about the general scope of
the problems I've worked on is oh sorry
one more slight what was the common
themes across these problems and where
machine learning can actually help so
before I go into that I found this RFC
for those of you who are fond networking
you know that RFC's are basically
standards in networking and they're
basically is from 1996 so it's even
before I think I was five at that point
maybe but I feel like this truths that
are said in that RFC so hold so first of
all some things in life can never be
appreciated or nor understood until you
actually do it yourself one of the
things that I've learned after three
years of collaborating with Azure
networking has been until you experience
the problems and if you don't have the
domain knowledge it's going to be really
really hard to create a solution that
the operators actually want to use and
can and is practical the second thing is
it's always it's always possible to have
multiple separate solutions to the
problem and try to combine them but when
you look but when you work with
operators one of the things that you
would notice is that they always prefer
the simplest solution you can provide
complex models that work really really
well in theory but in practice an
operator should be able to verify why
your model is not working so if I'm an
operator and if I look at the number
coming out of a system and I don't know
what it means if the system gives me a
wrong number at one point in time I want
to lose confidence in the system and I'm
never going to use it again and that
happens a lot so but going back to the
original question I asked which was why
do we need operators to manage our
networks today there are a couple of
reasons first of all the ideal data that
we need to figure out the cause of
problems is often missing the monitoring
we need is expensive a lot of times and
so one place that machine learning can
really really help is figuring out when
and where to initiate monitoring of
support type of data the other thing is
gathering the right data can be
expensive so that's another place where
I think we can contribute
sometimes it's not even clear what the
right data is to figure out the source
of a subset of these problems and
there's sometimes like the case in
network which we found is that there is
data that indirectly points to the cause
of the problem and sure causality is
important but sometimes correlation is
just enough and it's all that you need
so to sum it up this is where I think AI
can help if you can predict when a
failure is about to happen we can always
figure out what monitoring to turn on
and what that monitoring should be if
you can identify where the complex
correlations are and if you cannot
sometimes it's the case that you can't
avoid
operator involvement sometimes the
operator is needed to solve a problem
but if you can identify when that help
is actually needed and when the alert is
noise that would reduce pain in complex
platforms like a shirt by a lot so with
that I'll end with this other truth that
I find it's important to keep in mind
Thanks
[Applause]
sorry
whether deep learning or otherwise like
you know how do we interpret specially
like complex decision trees and
everything right so do you see that like
you know do you find like you know that
kind of work still being useful or is it
still too far away from like really
helping this domain so the way there's
two ways I find this useful and one of
them is slightly idiotic and what the
one that I find it most useful is when
you want to build operator trust in your
system or in your model it helps if they
understand Wyatt and how the model is
working or when it's not working why
it's not working
right and that is a place that I think
that's very much needed I've seen a lot
of systems built by as your networking
themselves where the system is deployed
it's very useful it makes a couple of
mistakes and people are like oh the
system is crap we're never gonna use it
again and that's not really true but
it's like people lost confidence in the
system so they're never gonna use it
again right so that's one thing but the
other thing I think is sometimes like in
the case of the TCP stuff the network
stuff that we did you can gain a lot of
knowledge about the protocol itself or
about the fundamentals of the system
itself from the explained ability of the
models like what we learned was a lot
about how TCP reacts to failures on the
server side that we didn't know before I
didn't expect to see so that was also
something like and that's part of the
reason we use decision trees because
they give you expelling ability but yeah
so those are the things I think where
this can be used
[Applause]